Với trường dự thảo thông tự hương sáng thực hiện trình mũ tự của Xe, về trong suất suất khoảng giân số phát triển.
Bản thân năm 2018, hành hương trang băm lắm, ở độ bối tế lấy kiến.
Cái địa phương sẽ tổ chứ khoáp chuyển bị của sống 1 nhân gia đình cho năm nữa trước khi kết hôn
và khuyến khách thành diễn tham gia.
Nếu dung khoáp dự kiến vộng, kinh thất kỹ năng bế hôn nhân gia đình,
xác khoảng sinh sản và xác khoảng tiền dục, mang thay sinh gòn luôn giải con, khoảng tiền gia đình.
Bối tế sẽ xí dự bộ tài liệu thông nhất chính tần quốc và tập hón lượng sản viên
các bộ y tế dân số để chiến khai tại thế địa phương.
Hành năm khoảng 20% sản phường đặc ho dự kiến tổ chựa ít nhất một lất học,
khoảng chuyến đe, giành cho thành nghiên trường bị lập gia đình.
Hãy bộ y tế để xuất đứa dân ra trong mối cạnh người dân kết hôn ngày khăn mỗi,
mất sinh của Việt Nam đã giảm xuống, có một phải chiến mốt còn trên một phụ nữ
tập hơn mất sinh thay thế.
Vì vậy, cùng với việc quyền thích kết hôn trước và miệng tội,
bị cho bị kiến thác cho hôn nhân được kỹ bạong gó phần xí dựa ra định biệt bấn,
năng mất sinh và cạnh thiện chứ lượng dân số.